[Musik]
jetzt also doch das was politiker in den
vergangenen wochen nie wollten passiert
der knallhart lockdown ab mittwoch alle
geschäfte dicht bis auf supermärkte
jetzt sagt man uns bis zum 10
januar aber wer soll das noch glauben
was passiert jetzt in deutschland wie
geht es weiter für die firmen und wie
viele menschen müssen um ihren job
fürchten und wann verdammt nochmal kommt
endlich der impfstoff hier auch in
deutschland ja darüber möchte ich
sprechen mit meinen gästen
bundeswirtschaftsminister peter altmaier
und volker wissing fdp generalsekretär
und wirtschaftsminister in rheinland
pfalz er altmaier
jetzt gibt es den knall hat lockdown ich
habe verstanden ist es so dramatisch
dass das jetzt passieren muss aber bevor
wir weiterreden will ich ihnen einmal
zeigen was am samstag in leipzig
passiert ist das ist nämlich ein
vorgeschmack was wir vielleicht in den
nächsten beiden tagen erleben
dem freistaat sachsen steht bereits ab
montag ein harter lockdown bevor der
rest der republik folgt am mittwoch
darauf hat sich angela merkel in einem
gipfeltreffen mit den ländern geeinigt
viele nutzten am samstag noch mal die
chance zum shoppen war nicht nur eine
spezies wo er sehr unerwartet dass sie
lesen jetzt so schnell sind und ich
wollte jetzt noch mal die letzten tag
nutzen hier in sachsen vor dem lot bauen
um wirklich den rest besorgen und ja die
geschäfte bis hin zu unterstützen
überraschend stellte ehrlich gesagt gar
nie damit gerechnet und jetzt wird halt
alles 30 auch überall in deutschland
waren die straßen überfüllt so auch in
nrw und baden württemberg wir hatten
eigentlich gedacht dass die stadt leer
sein wird und wir jetzt hier niemanden
treffen und sind definitiv überrascht
was los ist lange warteschlangen
eingängen und kassen wie hier in berlin
in frankfurt am main hatte op peter
feldmann sogar ausdrücklich zum shoppen
aufgerufen aber das kam offenbar nicht
bei jedem gut an
also mir gefällt diese situation zurzeit
nicht weil ich ich finde es da so ein
gegen wird so viele leute unterwegs sind
und wir hatten keinen abstand und
bringen sich überall vor
nach dem beschlossenen knallhart
lockdown zum 16 dezember könnte es in
den meisten deutschen städten am montag
und dienstag noch mal ähnlich aussehen
naja für sie als wirtschaftsminister sie
müssten doch jetzt eigentlich auch sagen
montag dienstag leute geht raus und
macht die läden leer
nein ganz im gegenteil ich wünsche mir
ja nicht hoffe dass die menschen erstens
nur das allernötigste besorgen was sie
wirklich brauchen an lebensmitteln und
dass wir ansonsten versuchen so schnell
wie möglich die beschlüsse umzusetzen
denn es geht um die gesundheit von ganz
vielen und es geht auch natürlich um
unseren wohlstand und je schneller wir
die infektionen unter kontrolle bekommen
desto besser ist es für alle eine hand
von ihnen zu hause zu bleiben jetzt in
den nächsten zwei tagen ja ich das ist
ein appell für alle besorgungen die
nicht unbedingt stattfinden müssen auf
die zu verzichten
dass man lebensmittel braucht das man
getränke braucht das kann jeder
verstehen güter des täglichen bedarfs
aber es gibt auch die möglichkeit das
ein oder andere shopping abenteuer
nach weihnachten zu machen wenn
irgendwann die geschäfte wieder geöffnet
werden wann das sein wird kann ihnen
niemand verantwortlich voraussagen
denn es gibt einen klaren maßstab und
das ist die entwicklung der infektionen
und der todesfälle
solange sie so hoch sind und jede woche
weiter zunehmen 10 15 prozent
steigerungen so lange ist unser
gesundheitssystem bedroht und sagt
unsere krankenhäuser unsere notaufnahmen
und solange ist die gesundheit von 80
millionen deutschen bedroht über die
notaufnahmen reden wir später mehr
wissen
verstehen sie das warum sie jetzt noch
montag dienstag einkaufen dürfen wenn
die lage so dramatisch ist wie die
bundesregierung sie beschreibt es muss
ja eine vorbereitung geben man kann
nicht alle geschäfte von sonntag auf
montag schließen und muss ja mindestens
möglich sein dass man mit den
mitarbeitern bespricht wie es weitergeht
da entstehen viele fragen und dass man
das jetzt geordnete auf den weg bringt
halte ich für richtig
man muss auch mit menschen führen die
das umsetzen müssen vor ort das ist ja
erstmal ein schock erlebnis für die
betroffenen unternehmen ein unternehmer
für viele mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter die sich sorgen machen wie
es weitergehen wird und dass man jetzt
sich die zwei tage nimmt das halte ich
für richtig aber es kommt natürlich
darauf an da gebe ich an altem recht
dass sich jeder jetzt verantwortungsvoll
verhält was ist mit den ladenöffnungen
kann man da flexibler jetzt sein
erwarten sie nachts shopping gibt es
jetzt schon um 6 uhr morgen früh los wie
können da ladenbesitzer an tieren also
wir müssen jetzt alle konzentriert und
diszipliniert uns an diese regeln der
notbremse handeln so wie es gelaufen ist
in den letzten wochen und monaten kann
es nicht weitergehen
wir brauchen jetzt eine strategie aber
vor der entwicklung einer strategie die
uns bis ins nächste jahr hinein
begleitet muss die notbremse kommen die
zahlen sind eindeutig ich möchte noch
einmal auf die frage zurückkommen was
das für unsere wirtschaft unsere
innenstädte bedeutet er alt meist gibt
ein tolles foto von ihnen finde ich
zumindest das gezeigt hat wie sehr sie
eintreten
gerade für läden für für
händler vor ort sie haben sich da
gezeigt mit einem fahrrad was die
kanzlerin ja auch als das das beste die
beste möglichkeit ausgewählt hat sie
sagen das ist eine patriotische aufgabe
aber jetzt passiert ja genau das was sie
sich ja nicht wollen nämlich dass alles
richtung online-handel wandert ja ich
habe dieses foto und dieses interview
vor mehreren wochen gemacht als die
infektions lager eine ganz andere war
und ich bleibe dabei dass wir ein
interesse haben unseren einzelhandel die
geschäfte in den innenstädten am leben
zu erhalten wir wollen keine verbündeten
städte wir wollen
lebendige einkaufsstadt genau da wird ja
aber weil wir aber weil wir aufgrund der
umstände gezwungen sind auch diese läden
zu schließen nicht die lebensmittelläden
aber die anderen die vielen anderen die
schuhgeschäfte und die
bekleidungsgeschäfte haben wir auch
dafür gesorgt dass dienstleistungen zur
verfügung stehen wir werden diesen
geschäften ihre fixkosten erstatten
wir werden ihnen darüber hinaus zu viele
andere kosten erstatten auch bei den
abschreibungen großzügiger sein wenn es
darum geht dass sie ware eingekauft
haben die verderblich ist wir wollen
dass sie überleben was ist ihr wäre sehr
auch lanka und weiter unterstützen
aber es müssen jetzt alle verstehen dass
es nicht um irgendwelche kleinigkeiten
geht sondern es geht wirklich um eine
ganz große und wichtige frage was ist
mit was ist mit der ware genau weil ich
glaube das haben viele heute noch nicht
verstanden was bekommen die händler
tatsächlich zurück erstattet was ist
damit den mieten
wie helfen sie da ganz konkret nun bei
den mieten ist es ganz ganz einfach die
werden erstattet das sind fixe kosten
es werden auch kosten erstattet für
mitarbeiter weiter beschäftigt werden
müssen nicht in kurzarbeit gehen können
in begrenztem umfang
es werden kosten erstattet für heizung
und für elektrizität für werbungskosten
wenn jemand für das weihnachtsgeschäft
geworden hat und das geld ist jetzt weg
aber das geschäft ist so kann man in
bestimmten grenzen auch das erstattet
bekommen
abschreibungen für neu angeschaffte
güter die an wert verlieren auch wenn
sie nicht benutzt werden
und dann gibt es natürlich ich bringe
mal ein ganz einfaches beispiel wenn ein
blumen
laden 500 weihnachtssterne bestellt hat
weil diese besonders gut verkäuflich
sind in der weihnachtszeit
dann wird man mit denen nach dem log
dann wenig anfangen können und deshalb
stellt sich die frage kann er das
stornieren
und wer nicht und dann muss
sichergestellt werden dass das
unbürokratisch möglich ist dass man das
absetzen kann
da wird der finanzminister eine
entsprechende regelung sehr zügig
schuldig das ist ja sehr wichtig
deswegen hab ich dann nochmal nach
können sie da noch weitere beispiele
gerade für shop besitzer die uns jetzt
vielleicht auch zu schauen die sorgen
haben um ihr geschäft also will lernt
weihnachtssterne die man dann nicht mehr
verkaufen kann zb die gibt es dann in
irgendeiner weise ersetzt vom stark was
fehlt da noch drunter
naja ich hab ich ja eben gesagt miete
und strom und licht und ausgaben die man
für für das personal hat was dafür
sorgen muss dass dass der laden nicht
verwahrlost und das alles in ordnung
bleibt wir haben das ja schon
praktiziert auch im frühjahr allerdings
auf niedrigerem niveau
jetzt gehen viele ladenbesitzer auf dem
zahnfleisch weil sie das ganze jahr über
umsatzrückgänge hatten und deshalb haben
wir diese hilfen ausgeweitet im frühjahr
aber am besten funktionieren ja heute
noch nicht mal also wenn wir die
november hilfen sehen für gastronomie
herr altmaier das müssen wir ganz klar
so sagen da sollte ein programm
programmiert werden und bis jetzt gibt
es diese november helfen eben nicht
verboten seien habe man das ist falsch
ist es einfach falsch ich habe als wir
das beschlossen haben sehr kurzfristig
zwei tage vor dem ersten november gesagt
wir machen abschlagszahlungen weil das
die einzige möglichkeit ist geld
überhaupt noch im november zu den
menschen zu bringen es ist rund sind
rund fast eine milliarde inzwischen an
abschlagszahlungen überwiesen
irgendwo zwischen 500 millionen und
einer milliarde an ganz ganz viele
hotels und gaststätten 75 jahren das und
das und es geht auch eben nicht so
schnell weil es beispielsweise damit
zusammenhängt dass kurzarbeitergeld
abgezogen wird von dem erstattungsbetrag
und sie wissen aber heute erst manchmal
sechs oder acht wochen später wie viele
kurzarbeiter geld zu bekommen
das sind schwierige fragen die zu klären
sind und im übrigen wenn es unternehmen
gibt die mehr
millionen umsatz erstattung bekommen
dann muss auch im interesse der
steuerzahler sichergestellt sein dass
die angaben zumindest einmal überprüft
werden können das wissen alle
beteiligten und diese plattform
funktioniert viel besser als alle
geglaubt haben wir haben sie übrigens
eingerichtet weil uns auch die länder
darum gebeten haben weil die länder
gesagt haben diesen ansturm können wir
in dieser form länder ist ein gutes
stichwort erwägen sie sind ja auch
wirtschaftsminister in rheinland pfalz
also sie erleben dass auch auf der
regierungsseite mit nicht sozusagen
ausschließlich in der oppositionsseite
als generalsekretär im bund wenn sie
jetzt hören dass zum beispiel der hde
warnt dass die pläne um zwölf milliarden
euro umsatz vernichten bis zu 250.000
euro jobs reicht das was er da sagt
wichtig ist das hat die bundeskanzlerin
ja in der debatte auch deutlich gemacht
dass die gelder jetzt so schnell wie
möglich fließen das wird eine
kraftanstrengung braucht dazu eine
zentrale software das macht keinen sinn
dass wir 16 programme entwickeln für
jedes land sein eigenes das verwirrt
dann auch die antragsteller werden es
ist richtig dass der bund das macht das
muss nur jetzt so schnell wie möglich
eben auch umgesetzt werde dann passiert
das dann also sie sind ja mit beteiligt
kann man sagen aber die länder können
diese auszahlungen erst vornehmen wenn
die software zur verfügung stellt und
die anträge die zentral eingegangen sind
in ländern zur bearbeitung zum als
freiheitsheld er hat mal können sie den
kaufleuten jetzt drei tage vor diesem
blitz lockdown ganz konkret sagen welche
hilfen sie wann bekommen also wir werden
morgen auch dafür sorgen dass das
veröffentlicht wird was die einzelheiten
angeht
die hilfen die sie angesprochen haben da
ist die software für die antragstellung
bereits seit dem 25
andere werden oder einander helfen im
november hilfen das funktioniert mit den
anträgen seit dem 25
november seit diesem zeitpunkt werden
auch abschlagszahlungen ausgezahlt wo es
darum geht was er bisher zu recht
angesprochen hat ist dass man für die
endabrechnung ebenfalls eine software
braucht die wird in den nächsten tagen
an den start gehen und dann wird
umgehend mit der auszahlung begonnen was
die überbrückungshilfen angeht die wir
jetzt zahlen für die geschäfte die neu
geschlossen werden haben wir ja heute
erst beschlossen
das muss mit den ländern noch einmal
diskutiert und besprochen werden und
dann wird es so zügig ist irgend geht
auch umgesetzt
auch dort wird es abschlagszahlungen
geben und was ist in einer größenordnung
bis in einer größenordnung von 50.000
euro das haben wir vereinbart was ist
mit den 75 prozent bar besitzer bekommen
und restaurantbesitzer im november 75
prozent umsatz erstattung wird das auch
für geschäfte gelten die jetzt in der
innenstadt in den log-dateien das haben
wir damals für die restaurantbesitzer
für die hotelbesitzer für die katalanen
dienstleistungen so und auch für kultur
unternehmen so gemacht weil es die
einzigen waren die schließen mussten
alle anderen durften geöffnet bleiben im
november
und auch jetzt im dezember bis nächste
woche und als es jetzt darum ging dass
wir generell den harten locker und wie
sie sagen verhängt haben aber in
verhängen mussten haben wir gesagt jetzt
wird ab dem 16
für die neu geschlossen werden und ab
dem ersten januar für die die weiterhin
geschlossen bleiben
ein anderes system gewählt weil
eigentlich das nein weil es
beihilferechtliche fragen sind die zu
klären sind und natürlich wir haben wir
haben selbstverständlich die möglichkeit
das alles zu finanzieren aber das geld
was wir dafür ausgeben steht für andere
aufgaben nicht so weil wir sehen ist das
gerät deshalb ist es richtig eine
verbesserte überbrückungshilfe zu machen
die dann den menschen ermöglicht ihre
kosten zurückzuweisen ist das gerecht
dass jetzt diejenigen die jetzt in dem
lockdown betroffen sind nicht die
gleiche summe bekommen die zum beispiel
restaurant und hotel besitzer bekommen
haben eben diese 75 prozent er stellt
sich in der tat die frage ob im dezember
nicht eine gleichbehandlung stattfinden
müsste das ist die frage ob man hier
verfassungsrechtlich nicht ein
gleichbehandlungs anspruch hat sind sie
dafür
ich bin sehr dafür allerdings muss man
auch dazu sagen dass wir dann noch ein
zusätzliches programm bräuchten um die
wenigen tage dezember für den handel
abzuwickeln
und wir kommen inzwischen wir haben
glaube ich sechs hilfsprogramme
inzwischen parallel laufen wir kommen an
eine administrative grenzen insofern
halte ich denke grundsätzlich für
richtig dass der bund sagt wir gehen
jetzt in die überbrückungshilfe 3 und
die halten wir dann auch durch bis mitte
nächsten jahres das ist der erste
schritt in eine gesamtstrategie die
ja schon lange auch von meiner partei
gefordert wird jetzt brauchen wir eine
strategie in allen bereichen die über
die nächsten treffen der
ministerpräsidenten hinaus trägt wie
gesagt über all ihre hilfsprogramme sind
zu viel genau wie das gesamtstrategie
möchten wir sprechen und dann noch einen
weiteren gast mit in die runde holen das
ist der oberbürgermeister von tübingen
da ist er
boris palmer der in dieser woche man
kann schon sagen so ein bisschen für
furore gesorgt hat weil er mit dem
programm was den schutz der alten angeht
gezeigt hat das ist eben zumindest in
seiner stadt auch anders gehen kann herr
palmer sie haben sicherlich die
diskussion hier gerade verfolgt aber
auch das große ganze das was die
kanzlerin zusammen mit den
ministerpräsidenten
da heute beschlossen hat macht das aus
ihrer sicht sinn dieser knallhart locker
ich glaube wir haben keine andere chance
mehr das muss jetzt zu sagen ja das
heißt das muss so sein sagen sie aber
sie haben ja auf einen anderen weg
gesetzt haben sie eine erklärung dafür
dass den altenheim in den pflegeheimen
dass da in ganz deutschland das ganze
bislang anders gehandhabt wurde als bei
ihnen sie haben ein spezielles modell
entwickelt auch wie rentner zum beispiel
einkaufen gehen sollen was
taxigutscheine angeht ist es da dringend
an der zeit dass das ganze auch in ganz
deutschland passieren
ich glaube es lohnt jetzt nicht mehr die
frage zu stellen warum ist es nicht
früher gefunden worden
da könnte man darüber reden ich glaube
muss nach vorne schauen und da ist es
doch einfach so dass wir schon aus den
erfahrungen unserer nachbarländer aber
auch aus berchtesgaden wissen auch nach
einem knallharten locker und dauert es
relativ lange bis die zahlen runter
gehen und es ist nicht sehr
wahrscheinlich dass wir am 10 januar
aufwachen und wir sind dann schon bei 50
oder weniger angekommen und dann ist
immer noch winter und nach vorne gedacht
bis zum frühjahr brauchen wir eine neue
strategie und das ist es was wir in
thüringen zu ergänzen versucht haben wir
haben einerseits die säule kontakt
beschränkungen natürlich
die regeln die müssen wir weitermachen
aber es können zwei weitere sollen
hinzukommen damit wir uns jetzt nicht
auf drei oder vier monate locker und
festlegen müssen und die zweite säule
ist der schutz der risikogruppen
das haben wir in thüringen und versucht
mit akzeptablem erfolgt denke ich ganz
zufrieden bin ich nicht weil auch wir
jetzt die ersten infektionen in
pflegeheimen haben
da gibt es noch lücken die werden
hoffentlich noch geschlossen und zur
dritten säule nämlich effizienten
kontakt versorgung sollten wir uns jetzt
auch gedanken machen wenn wir nicht bis
10 januar die app endlich scharf
schalten dann werden wir wahrscheinlich
nicht rauskommen aus diesen winterschlaf
und ich glaube das ist jetzt die aufgabe
der politik nach vorne zu schauen das
besser zu machen
altmaier palma sagt wir werden
wahrscheinlich da am 10 januar noch
nicht raus sein er sagt wir müssen die
app endlich scharf stellen und das wäre
meine frage warum haben wir nicht längst
viel mehr für die alten in unserem land
getan
wir haben für die alten sehr viel getan
aber man kann besser werden und ich habe
schon in der letzten woche gelegenheit
gehabt das beispiel von tübingen und von
boris palmer auch positiv zu würdigen
ich glaube dass sollten sich alle sehr
genau anschauen und sehen was man davon
lernen kann
leider ist aber auch richtig dass in
tübingen bei den älteren die
ansteckungen viel niedriger sind als
anderswo aber insgesamt auch in tübingen
der wert von 50 infektionen pro 100000
einwohnern leider überschritten ist wie
überall in deutschland
das ist kein problem von tübingen
sondern wir haben glaube ich noch genau
einen landkreis ja unter 50 neue
infektionen über sieben tage 100.000
einwohner hat und das zeigt wie
dramatisch die lage ist und deshalb
müssen wir gute beispiele aufgreifen
wir müssen bereit sein zu lernen von
denen die irgendwo erfolg haben aber es
bleibt trotzdem eine große
kraftanstrengung
wir haben aber gesehen dass länder um
uns herum es tatsächlich geschafft haben
mit konsequentem vorgehen die zahlen so
zu senken dass was wir immer hinten
januar glauben sie am 10 januar sind wir
dann durch was denken sie ja wir sind
wahrscheinlich nicht das muss man ganz
offen sagen denn wir wissen dass er erst
14 tage verzögert sich
eine veränderung des infektionsgeschehen
es wirklich in den zahlen abbildet
deswegen ist es nicht sehr
wahrscheinlich dass wir mit dem zehnter
januar den lockdown hier wieder
vollständig beenden können und ob man
dann zu offen öffnung kommt weiß ich
auch nicht wir haben das problem dass
dieser wellenbrecher lockdown
offensichtlich nicht funktioniert hat
das war ein experiment mir war das nie
eingeleuchtet weil wir nämlich
infektionen in der fläche hatten wenn
sie sich ein beispiel ich war das
rheinland pfalz die eifel anschauen wenn
sich die leute im dorf infiziert die
haben sich nicht im museum angesteckt
nicht in kultureinrichtungen angesteckt
und auch nicht in der gastronomie
angesteckt wenn man aber diese bereiche
schließt kann man nicht erwarten dass
die infektionen dort zurückgehen und das
war das problem aber es hilft jetzt
nichts zurück zu blicken aber es
interessiert die heimischen was ist mit
dem zehnten januar man jetzt sagt auch
er wissen herr papa sagen alle zehn
jahre 90 alles wir sind uns dort alle
drei einig weil es ja so ist dass
diejenigen die in fünf in zehn tagen
krank werden diejenigen sind die sich
heute schon infiziert haben das ist
erstmal die traurige wahrheit
zweitens haben wir gesehen dass das
virus inzwischen in der fläche auch
derart verbreitet ist dass es nicht so
leicht ist schneller erfolge zu erzielen
wie das im frühjahr noch möglich war
wie lange der klagen ist jetzt halt ein
deshalb haben es anhängern mit einem
verantwortlich kann ihn niemand sagen
wie lange und verantwortlich kann ihnen
noch niemand sagen ob es unverändert so
weitergeht ob einige dinge geändert
werden deshalb werden wir uns nach dem
ministerpräsidenten am 5 januar noch
einmal zusammen das werden die lage
jedoch wahrscheinlich werden wir das
jetzt jeden tag hören und der
bundesregierung aber trotzdem die
menschen wollen planen sie wollen wissen
was passieren kann sie habe gerade beide
selbst gesagt ist es sehr unrealistisch
dass es am 10 januar wieder losgeht ist
es dann eher februar oder märz oder
april womit rechnen sie
wenn ich der liebe gott wäre könnte ich
ihre frage beantworten aber sie sind ja
ein schlauer mensch das ja aber wir
haben ein klares prinzip und dieses
prinzip sagt die gesundheit der
bürgerinnen und bürger der jungen aber
auch der älteren und egal ob jemand 80
90 oder 100 ist er ist ein mensch mit
seiner ganz unverwechselbaren würde das
steht für uns im vordergrund er lauter
monate zum wandel lauterbach
den ich ebenfalls kenne und schätze aus
langer parlamentarischer gemeinsamkeit
ist aber kein hellseher und niemand kann
vorhersehen wie sich das entwickelt im
frühjahr haben wir sehr schnell sehr
schnelle erfolge erzielt einem
wellenbrecher locker und nicht so
schnell ich will da auch gar keine
vergangenheitsbewältigung machen woran
es gelegen hat tatsache ist jedenfalls
wir mussten nachlegen
das ist keine von uns leicht gefallen
und wenn wir auch nur eine woche zu früh
wieder die zügel lockern und sagen jetzt
geht es wieder los dann besteht die
gefahr dass wir den dritten rückfall
erleiden dass wir die dritte welle
bekommen und das wollen wir gerne
verhindern
also lieber ein bisschen zu lang als ein
bisschen zu kurz
das ist ein bisschen zu vereinfacht
gesagt ich glaube es muss so lange sein
wie es notwendig ist und deshalb darf
man sich nicht unter druck setzen lassen
indem man sagt zu einem bestimmten datum
wird geöffnet koste es was es wolle
und egal wie wir halten fest keiner in
dieser und glaubt daran dass es am
zehnten jahr nur wirklich wieder losgeht
da frage ich mich so ein bisschen warum
konnte die kanzlerin das heute nicht
sagen aber wir möchten zu der diskussion
in den lockdown nochmal eine weitere
stimme zeigen dass es professor ludger
der im ethikrat in bayern sitzt und da
ausgerechnet bayerns ministerpräsident
markus söder mit berät kann man sagen es
ist sehr spannend was er zum lockdown
gesagt hat was wir derzeit erleben ist
im grunde der offenbarungseid der
deutschen corona politik denn wir haben
immer gesagt in deutschland der lok tor
und ist das schlechteste was kommen kann
wir wollen das auf jeden fall vermeiden
und jetzt erleben wir ihn doch und auch
noch mal schärfer das heißt ich glaube
dass wir wirklich hier kurzfristig
gesehen einmal schwere wirtschaftliche
schädigungen haben aber auch
medizinische gesundheitliche schäden und
langfristig wird das viele weitere
psychische und auch soziale nach
langzeit folgen nach sich ziehen
das ist eine politik die das vertrauen
der menschen vollkommen verspielt
mal spielen sie das vertrauen der
menschen und sorgen sie dafür dass ist
mehr psychische schäden zum beispiel bei
den menschen geben nein eindeutig nein
es gibt ein großes vertrauen der
bürgerinnen und bürger in die politik
nicht in eine bestimmte partei aber in
die politik das wir gemeinsam mit dieser
sache fertig werden ich habe sehr genau
zugehört und das war bestimmt auch ein
fachmann der ehe seinen kommentar
abgegeben hat aber was ich vermisst habe
waren klare vorstellungen und vorschläge
was man denn stattdessen machen soll und
man kann darüber diskutieren ob der
locker und so wirksam ist wie wir uns
das vorgestellt haben solche
diskussionen müssen von
gesundheitsexperten geführt werden aber
der entscheidende punkt ist doch wenn
ich sage diese maßnahme nicht welche
maßnahme denn dann
denn wenn man gar nichts macht dann
werden wir infektionszahlen bekommen wie
in den usa
und das ist glaube ich in unserer
gesellschaft niemandem vermittelbar
herr palmer sie sind beim thema corona
da als kritischer geist kann man sagen
aufgefallen dass ein bisschen anders
gemacht hat wenn sie jetzt sehen was
dieser professor der dort im ethikrat
sitzt gesagt hat über den lockdown auch
über die psychischen schäden über die
konsequenzen die wir vielleicht gerade
noch gar nicht sehen können was er dort
berichtet hat wie nehmen sie das wahr
wie gefährlich wird jetzt dieser
lockdown auf anderen ebenen
so wie es gesagt hat das kann man
überhaupt nicht bestreiten locker und
kann eigentlich nur das letzte mittel
sein wir haben nichts anderes mehr übrig
bleibt weil außer schwere nebenwirkungen
hat da hat er recht
und es ist trotzdem so dass wir jetzt
aktuell nur noch auf dieses letzte
mittel zurückgreifen können er will aber
noch einmal erläutern was meiner meinung
nach getan werden könnte bis zum 10
januar damit wir nicht jetzt in langen
lockdown hineinrutschen
und das sind die beiden anderen säulen
die vorgeschaltet eben gestärkt werden
müssen
da ist zum einen das tessin wir haben
eben den thüringern seit august versucht
sehr engmaschig zu testen das personal
die besucher und die bewohner von
pflegeheimen bis anfang dieser woche
haben das geschafft ist wer was nicht
rein zu lassen
wir konnten das aber nur freiwillig tun
jetzt wird endlich eine pflicht zu
diesen tests eingeführt nach meiner
meinung darf niemand mehr einen
pflegeheim rein der nicht am eingang
getestet wurde und dann müsste es uns
gelingen dass wir es dort draußen zu
halten und es wird ein großteil der
todesfälle unter belastung und zwei
intensivstationen vermeiden ist das eine
was unbedingt gemacht werden muss bis 10
januar dass dieses system im tag des
schleusensystem für die altenpflege und
das 2d und da wundere ich mich warum das
bisher einfach nicht vorangetrieben
wurde ist die app scharf zu stellen
wissen sie es ist doch absurd dass
werner industrienationen leben und die
kanzlerin sagen muss bei 75 prozent der
fälle haben wir keine ahnung wo sich die
menschen anstecken
das stimmt gar nicht unsere handys
wissen ist die korona bis 20 millionen
handys installiert und trotzdem gps da
da wenn wir endlich zu lassen würden auf
diese daten zugreifen hätten wir in
kürzester zeit hunderttausende von
datensätzen das den wir endlich erkennen
könnten wo das virus sich eigentlich
ausbreitet an welchen orten und daraus
kann man wissenschaftlich ableiten
welche situationen sind die wir
beherrschen müssen wir müssen runter von
diesem datenschutz kult es muss bis 10
januar gelingen das zugriff auf diese
informationen der app ermöglicht wird
und dass sie so ausgerollt wird dass sie
auch wirklich verpflichtend für alle die
ein entsprechendes handy haben denn zur
nutzung vorgeschrieben wird wir können
doch nicht den leuten weihnachten das
einkaufen des freunde besuchen er alles
mögliche verbieten aber davor
zurückschrecken endlich die modernen
techniken zu nutzen wie das südkorea und
hermann
hoch erfolgreich gemacht haben ich
erwarte dass darüber jetzt endlich mal
eine offene diskussion geführt wird die
grundrechts einschränkung und sind viel
härter als das was wir beim datenschutz
erreichen können das ist das tun ja
warum ist diese app nicht scharf warum
funktioniert das nicht weil sie
funktioniert schon indem sie die
menschen warnt wenn sie risiko
begegnungen hatten
ich habe eben noch mal nachgeschaut hat
in den letzten fünf tagen auch eine
risiko begegnung mit niedrigem risiko
allerdings aber das ist der
entscheidende punkt wir haben uns damals
darauf verständigt das beispiel südkorea
war ja allen bekannt dort wird aber in
die privatsphäre sehr viel stärker
eingegriffen und das war bei allen
politischen parteien von cdu csu obmann
ändern sich fdp grünen war ein großer
und breiter konsens dass wir dieses
modell nicht durchführen wollen wir
hatten heute eine
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz man von all
diesen parteien auch ministerpräsidenten
und landesregierungen vertreten und die
diskussion ist nicht geführt worden wenn
herr palmer einen vorschlag machen
möchte wie er datenschutz und rechtliche
ansprüche die es gibt auch privatsphäre
vereinbart mit dem was er vorschlägt
dann wird das sicherlich gerne
angeschaut aber ich kann nur sagen dass
japaner ist als im augenblick das im
raum und lege seine augen
ja ich bin also um das mal zu sagen wir
haben hier in der bundesregierung auch
klare zuständigkeiten
ich bin für meine zuständigkeiten
jederzeit auch bereit eine klare kante
zu zeigen
die app ist nicht in meinem ministerium
angesiedelt das wetter ist schuld in der
bundesregierung es geht nicht um schuld
nein es geht nicht um schuld ich glaube
dass das der kanzleramtsminister der
gesundheitsminister wer die gemeinsam
diese app zustande gebracht haben haben
noch in der letzten woche deutlich
gemacht über 1,5 millionen menschen sind
gewarnt worden weil sie einen kontakt
hatten mit jemand der infiziert war
das heißt die app funktioniert die frage
ist ob sie gut genug funktioniert und
die frage ist was nimmt man denn dann
dafür in kauf in südkorea ist es
beispiel so also so dass sie dann eine
push meldung bekommen auf ihr handy
und da steht in ihrem bus sitzt jemand
der mit krone infiziert ist so das ist
dort ganz selbstverständlich ein paar
wollte weiß nicht ob das bei uns auch
dass bei uns akzeptabel wäre eine solche
situation und wie wir damit umgehen
würden hätten wir heute direkt zu ihrem
vorschlag glaube ich dass er nach berlin
kommen sollte als sonderberater für die
fdp hätten sie lust ihr im
gesundheitsministerium und beim
kanzleramt mal zu erklären was man dort
machen sollte aus ihrer sicht bei der
app ich glaube nicht dass ich das muss
das ist allen bekannt und es geht eher
um das was er als magath gesagt hat
nämlich die abwägung was ist uns
wichtiger und ich bin schon seit april
in die öffentlichkeit meter these
getreten ich verzichte auf meine daten
kontrolle wenn dafür dass stadt bescheid
weiß wo sich dieses virus bewegt weil es
bewegt sich ja immer in menschen und
darüber müssen wir diskutieren und ob
uns diese eingriffe in die privatsphäre
was die daten angeht ob uns die
schwerwiegende erscheinen oder der
eingriff dass ich jetzt nicht mehr als
fünf erwachsene personen an weihnachten
oder vor weihnachten treffen kann dann
möglicherweise die nachbarn die polizei
rufen der sechs erwachsene sind ich
finde diesen zweiten eingriff in meinem
leben viel härter und viel dramatisch
und es sind auch noch zeit weitere
grundrechte betroffen deswegen sage ich
die politische debatte wo wir ansetzen
ist nötig wenn ich würde gerne für ein
halbes jahr auf dem datenschutz
verzichten denn die gesundheits eben da
endlich wissen wo dieses virus sich
ausbreiten will sing ein halbes jahr auf
den datenschutz verzichten sie als
generalsekretär einer liberalen partei
wie sehen sie das
also zunächst einmal gilt auch in der
pandemie bekämpfung unserer verfassung
wir können nur auf der grundlage des
grundgesetzes arbeiten alle anderen
forderungen helfen überhaupt nichts wenn
die angeordnet werden vom
verfassungsgericht aufgehoben werden hat
man gar nichts in der hand was ich aber
wichtig finde ist das was er einmal als
zweiter vorschlag gemacht hat das ist
das thema wohl nabu-gruppen schützen die
gefährdeten stärker schützen einmal die
app zu ende sprechen dann wissen wie
stehen sie dazu weil das ist ja die
eltern gerichtet internet eine ganz
menschliche menschlicher wunsch stehen
herr palmer dort äußert nämlich dass er
sagt ich möchte lieber wieder etwas
normaler leben und dafür die app nutzen
als andersrum zunächst einmal die
kam sehr spät wir werden müssen das auch
kritisch rückblickend sehen das hätte
man früher haben müssen man hat ja sehr
früh schon modelle einer pandemie
seitens der bundesregierung
durchleuchtet aber sich mit der frage zu
beschäftigen wie kann man einer solchen
pandemie digital vorgehen um die
pandemie zu bekämpfen diese maßnahmen
sind sehr spät ergriffen worden
natürlich brauchen wir eine debatte um
die frage wie gehen wir mit datenschutz
um wie gehen wir mit grundrechtsschutz
in einer solchen situation
ich habe viel verständnis für die
position von ein paar mehr sagt der
eingriff in die privatsphäre der jetzt
stattfindet einander teilweise in
manchen bundesländern sogar ausgangs
beschränkungen die ich zum teil ehrlich
gesagt für völlig unverhältnismäßig
kalte aber das sind schon massive
eingriffe und dann zu sagen wir brauchen
eine debatte darüber wie viel der daten
die von der app erhoben werden nutzen
wir um rauszukriegen wo ist das erste
mal klartext er wird aber das gericht
insoweit wird klagt kann aber nicht so
wollen gern datenschutz wenn dadurch die
app bessere ich bin der meinung dass wir
darüber diskutieren müssen wo die
grenzen des datenschutzes sind in der
abwägung zu dem massiven
grundrechtseingriff die wir jetzt
erleben ich bin aber nicht dafür dass
wir zu solchen zuständen kommen wie herr
altmann ja soeben beschrieben hat von
korea
das wären quasi völlig entblößt wird
wenn die die app informationen über über
eine infektion im eigenen körper hat
oder ein infektionsrisiko im eigenen
körper also das darf nicht passieren
insofern wir sind nicht gut vorbereitet
gewesen digital das muss man
rückblickend sehen
deutschland hätte sich besser
vorbereiten müssen man hätte diese
möglichkeiten stärker nutzen müssen und
wir brauchen in der tat diese debatte
was wir jetzt aber nichts hilft ist
zurück zu blicken und zu sagen was ist
alles versorgen worden jetzt muss wir
wollen nicht ich will ein aspekt noch
der ganz wichtig ist nämlich noch nicht
genannt worden
wir kommen aus diesem block dann nur
dann schnell raus wenn wir sie dies dass
im moment der eigenverantwortung der
menschen aktivieren
deswegen brauchen wir in den nächsten
wochen eine aufklärungskampagne der
bundesregierung für so viele dinge
selbst der tag der offenen tür der
bundesregierung schengen überall plakate
aufklärung über das richtige verhalten
das brauchen wir jetzt dringend ich
wünsche mir eine breite plakatierung
informationen für die bürgerinnen und
bürger wir müssen den menschen erklären
erklären erklären viele dachten wenn die
gastronomie geschlossen ist kann man die
freunde ja nach hause zum essen einladen
das absurd
es ist das gleiche infektionsrisiko wenn
die leute müssen klar aufgeklärt werden
deswegen ist es auch nicht gut dass wir
ständig diskutieren zehn leute an
weihnachten 68 45 das ist nicht das
problem das problem ist dass man mit
möglichst wenig menschen kontakt haben
soll
denen maniche im alltag ohnehin begegnet
familie nächste familie und das den
menschen zu erklären ist ganz wichtig
aber das möchte ich ganz ganz
unterstützen sondern weil ich habe eine
frage an herrn william ist jetzt
ernsthaft eine informationskampagne die
größte forderungen die die
oppositionspartei an die bundesregierung
nahe die größte forderung der
oppositionspartei war gewesen die wohl
der vielen gruppen zu schützen und eine
palme hat gerade gezeigt dass es in
tübingen funktioniert hätte man das
früher begonnen werden werden
möglicherweise besser dastehen der
vorschlag der opposition war eine
gesamtstrategie zu entwickeln ich habe
immer gesagt dass es ein experiment mit
dem wellenbrecher locker und das ist ja
faktisch nicht erfolgreich gewesen aber
man muss auch der bundesregierung zu
gestehen sie experimentiert man muss
irgendwann mal wir haben jetzt diese
pandemie schon seit märz zu einer
strategie kommen die man über par monat
direkt nicht ständig andere ein paar
wort seiner straße man soll sich nicht
versammelt meine hilft dass wir ein
freies land sind nun niemand ist
gezwungen eine tageszeitung zu lesen
niemand ist gezwungen die
fernsehnachrichten anzuschauen niemand
ist gezwungen sich im internet über
corona zu informieren und es gibt halt
eben menschen die das gar nicht
mitbekommen was beschlossen wird und das
ist eine aufgabe sowohl der
bundesregierung als auch die
us-regierung der 16 wir haben und dafür
zu sorgen dass unsere beschlüsse nicht
nur ihnen herr uns war bekannt sind
nicht nur ihren interview gästen sondern
dass sie jedem einzelnen jungen oder
älteren menschen bekannt sind also das
ist das hatten die beiden
wirtschaftsministerium studio starten
jetzt gemeinsam eine infokampagne über
die risiken wochen vor ihr haben seit
monaten dass die bunt aber darf ich noch
mal aus der praxis anwendet und erklärt
was sie warum für erforderlich hält
viele dinge werden nicht genügend
erklärt und die menschen wollen
verstehen sie wollen das erklärt
bekommen ich verstehe ihren anderen
heime sie wollten genau dazu noch etwas
sagen ja ich glaube nicht dass wir es
mit zu wenig aufgeklärten menschen in
unserem land zu tun haben
sondern die leute diesen ja selbst zu
wenig habe es gerade gesagt wenn wir
nicht wissen wo die infektionen sind wie
soll warst du den leuten erklären aber
aus der praxis kann ich ihnen nur sagen
das problem der kontakt verfolgung ist
das entscheidende
wir haben bei uns mal analysiert wie
lange es dauert ist die zustellung der
quarantäne anordnung erfolgt ich muss
ihnen leider sagen dieser weg den wir da
hin dass machen vom gesundheitsamt über
die städtische behörde über die post es
muss nämlich per post verschickt werden
bei der datenschutz auch dagegen ist
dass man das anders markt dauert so
lange ist die kontakt verfolgung auch
bei 50 fehlen also wenn wir das ziel
erreicht hätten
meistens langsamer ist als des virus und
wenn wir nicht unsere kontakt verfolgung
auf moderne taten technik umstellen und
damit meine ich jetzt nicht irgendeine
software im gesundheitsamt sondern das
über die app sofort eingeschritten wird
dann werden wir in den nächsten lockdown
rutschen auch nach dem 10
denn andere länder uns doch vormachen
dass man das bei bestimmten eingriffen
in den datenschutz schaffen kann dann
finde ich diese debatte schon eine
ministerpräsident kretschmann hat dazu
meines wissen zahlt man da schon vor
zwei wochen und empire vorgelegt stand
somit es in der zeitung mit vielen
vielen maßnahmen wie die app scharf
gestellt werden kann zum beispiel dass
man nicht mehr selber wenn man infiziert
ist und den kopf voll hat mit vielen
problemen aktiv jemand anrufen muss um
die warnung loszutreten sondern dass
diese entscheidung automatisch erfolg
wenn ich mich für die app entscheide
dann entscheide ich mich für
automatische entwarnung also meiner
meinung aller meiner kontakte und
übrigens derzeit aktivieren nur 50
prozent der leute dann die warnung das
heißt da geht schon mal die hälfte der
wirkung der app verlorenen einfacher
pragmatischer vorschlag der bestimmt
nicht gegen das grundgesetz läuft und
die debatte wird einfach zu wenig
geführt wir müssen gucken dass die
kontakt verfolgung rauskommt aus dem
neunzehnten jahrhundert wo man mit
postboten läuft gut endlich im 21
mit hightech geführt werden wie schmerz
des zu sehen also ist das kostet dass
wir da nicht baden gehen
er hat man ja vielleicht als letzte
antwort zu etwas können wir jetzt tun um
die vorschläge von herrn palma mit herrn
sparen den sie erkennen und vielleicht
auch herrn brown zusammen zu bringen für
uns alle
um diese app zu verbessern also ich
werde die beiden falls sie nicht sowieso
heute abend schon ganz sind
das hier zuschauen davon gehe ich aus
morgen bei erstbester gelegenheit auch
darüber noch mal informieren was du
heute diskutiert haben
das problem ist bekannt die diskussion
auch sie vom ersten tag an
wir waren nicht so schnell wie korea das
ist richtig
wir waren aber in europa mit die ersten
und wir waren diejenigen wo die app am
besten funktioniert das muss man auch
dazu sagen wenn wir das was auch gut
läuft nicht auch mal als gut würdigen
und anerkennen dann werden wir erleben
dass menschen das vertrauen verlieren
die app könnte besser sein dann müsste
man aber in der tat beim datenschutz
kompromisse machen und den kauf nehmen
das war bislang bei allen grossen
politischen parteien nicht die gesprächs
möchte ein weiteres thema natürlich zu
corona anschneiden aber wo man auch das
gefühl hat wo deutschland im vergleich
zumindest heute nicht besonders gut da
steht das ist das thema impfen
wir erleben das jetzt um uns herum in
großbritannien in den usa in saudi
arabien sogar in israel das impfen
losgeht mit einem in deutschland
entwickelten impfstoff herr wissing
haben sie da irgendein verständnis dass
wir nicht längst in den pflegeheimen
begonnen haben mit dem impfen da sagen
erster politiker bereits dass wir damit
tote zusätzliche corona tod in kauf
wir brauchen so schnell wie möglich die
zulassung des impfstoffs aber die muss
auch auf einer sorgfältigen prüfung
basierend sonst haben die menschen nicht
das vertrauen in die impfung und wenn
die menschen sich nicht impfen lassen
dann hilft der impfstoff an sich wenig
deswegen brauchen wir so schnell wie
möglich eine sorgfältige prüfung und
zulassung der impfstoffe ist also die
briten haben unzuverlässigen impfstoff
die amerikaner die iss halten sich
derzeit überhaupt doch niemand aber es
gibt regeln es gibt regeln wann ein
impfstoff in verkehr gebracht werden
kann
auch nicht so dass alle um uns herum
impfen
weder in frankreich oder auch luchsen
kraft sogar den ersten deutschen die
heute in london aber weder in frankreich
noch den luxus mit einem george w
dänemark noch in finnland noch in
norwegen wird geimpft warum weil wir
eine europäische behörde haben die
zulassung dieses impfstoffs regelt wenn
er verdreht die einfach lama anderen
behörden und auf dieser welt wenn sie
davon ausgehen wenn sie davon ausgehen
dass wir millionen menschen impfen
werden
und wenn nur bei einem kleinen teil von
denen probleme entstehen dann haben sie
am nächsten tag die diskussion
wahrscheinlich auch bei ihnen in der
sendung hätte man nicht lieber noch
warten müssen am ende
am ende werden menschen in gefahr
gebracht weil sie empfindlicher ansagen
und jetzt eine sache erhalten muss sich
unterbrechen dann sagen sie
bibi netanjahu boris johnson und
momentan donald trump spielen mit der
gesundheit ihrer bürger wir haben eine
verantwortung für unsere bürgerinnen und
bürger und wir wollen dass dieser
impfstoff so schnell wie möglich
verfügbar ist und dafür haben wir eine
behörde mit hervorragenden fachleuten
für ganz europa und die wird entscheiden
wann es losgeht und wir hoffen dass dies
in wenigen tagen der fall ist aber noch
einmal über gesundheitsrisiken können
weder herr wissingen noch herr palmer
noch herr altmaier entscheiden auch
nicht sie obwohl sie sicherlich
herausragende qualitäten haben das
müssen die ärzte machen die mediziner
die fachleute und auf deren urteil
werden uns hoffentlich die qualität
richtige fragen zu stellen deswegen
möchte ich ihnen jetzt noch einmal ein
bild aus dem aus den usa zeigen was mich
tatsächlich heute neidisch gemacht hat
muss ich sagen da sehen wir die trucks
die durch die usa fahren und die man
muss sagen den in deutschland
entwickelten impfstoff dort verteilen
diese sind geschützt von marsh wir haben
bilder auch gesehen aus großbritannien
aber da in den usa ist das ganze noch
mal viel emotionaler aufbereitet und ich
habe mich gefragt herr altmaier als ich
diese bilder gesehen habe und die habe
ich ungefähr zum gleichen zeitpunkt
gesehen als sie dort in der video
konferenz saßen und gut erstmals haben
sich nicht gestritten mit allen anderen
aber gut es waren ja keine schönen
nachrichten die sie da verbreitet haben
der oder die kanzlerin und markus söder
wenn man jetzt überlegt hatte zum
gleichen zeitpunkt wären da trucks ums
brandenburger tor gefahren und
uns gezeigt es gibt hoffnung wir haben
diesen impfstoff das werde auch heute
wir hätten viel bessere laune oder seien
sie überzeugt dass die trucks auch in
deutschland fahren werden
ich bin überzeugt schon in ganz wenigen
tagen warum kann ich als politiker auch
den menschen sagen ihr können vertrauen
haben und wir haben alles mögliche
eingehalten und beachtet was notwendig
ist in einer modernen gesellschaft muss
lacht naja die meisten eines sie müssen
eine szene in den usa hat es einen not
zu lassen gegeben warum die große not
zulassung gibt es dort weil die zahl der
infektionen und vor allen dingen die
zahl der toten um ein vielfaches soll
ich als alle anderen länder auch noch
einmal auf 10 saudi-arabien israel
großbritannien sie können doch jetzt
nicht nur sagen weil in den usa die die
vergebens sucht kann ihnen ich kann
ihnen mindestens für jedes land das sie
mehr aufzählen 2 oder 3 auf djerba denen
es noch nicht zugelassen haben weil sie
sagen wir beachten die regeln die für
alle gelten
und ich könnte die verantwortung wenn
ich wenn ich an der stelle in der
regierung wäre nicht übernehmen zu sagen
wir machen eine politisch verordnete
impfkampagne ohne dass die busse aber
das gemeint haben muss nachdem auch da
muss ich nachfragen herr lauterbach hat
heute gesagt diejenigen die das jetzt
verschleppen und er sagt er kann es
nicht verstehen warum es diese
verzögerung gibt sind am ende mit
verantwortlich für den tod von menschen
ja wollen sie lieber verantwortlich
seiten für den tod von menschen oder
wollen sie dafür verantwortlich sein
dass sie jetzt einen impfstoff endlich
zu lassen der in großbritannien
zugelassen worden ist in israel in
bahrain und saudi arabien und in den usa
noch einmal ich glaube sie hier haben
die argumente ausgetauscht
wir wollen dass er möglichst schnell
zugelassen wird aber über die frage der
gesundheit unserer bürgerinnen und
bürger in frankreich in deutschland in
den niederlanden entscheidet nicht saudi
arabien und entscheidet nicht bahrain
aber nicht solange noch nicht mal
großbritannien
ich habe im übrigen behörden dieser
länder
aber es ist in all diesen ländern eine
note zulassung gewesen jedenfalls in den
usa und aber die situation schien durch
haben wir uns entschieden wir haben uns
entschieden den sicheren weg zu gehen
und wir möchten absacker bisschen gesagt
dass die menschen vertrauen haben und
sich impfen lassen
wenn sie am ende nämlich nur die hälfte
oder nur ein drittel impfen lässt weil
es komplikationen gegeben hat dann
hätten wir einen großen und schweren
fehler gemacht den man nicht wieder mit
ihnen noch eine stelle haben wir von der
lücke der ja im ethik beirat in bayern
sitzt er sich auch zum thema impfstoff
geäußert hat der impfstoff ist in
deutschland mitentwickelt worden wieso
man jetzt hier wochenlang darauf warten
dass das ist völlig unverständlich der
impfstoff ist da wir müssen den in die
bevölkerung bringen ich bin kein
impfgegner ich würde mich auch sofort
impfen lassen ich glaube das ist auch
wichtig egal was die sonst die situation
ist ob er aus medizinischen gründen
notwendig ist oder nicht aber wir
brauchen diesen impfstoff jetzt um
einfach aus der politischen situation
und aus der völlig verfahrenen enge
wieder rauszukommen die wehr geraten
sind und es ist ein professor der tu
münchen ich möchte noch einmal auch ein
paar fragen herr palmer wie sehen sie
die diskussion über den impfstoff fall
herrn alt marler ungern den rücken auch
wenn ich jetzt in seinem rücken sie
wolle ihn sehr schätze
aber ich sehe das anders die
verträglichkeits studien sind bei den
impfstoffen von denen wir sprechen ja
schon lange vorbei das heißt wir wissen
dass die sicher sind in dem maße wie
medikamente sicher sein können extrem
seltene ausnahmen sind da immer noch
möglich aber dadurch herrscht klarheit
die frage der wirkung ist noch nicht so
sicher die werden wir möglicherweise
auch erst wenn der in massenhaft
einsetzen dann wirklich genau beurteilen
können denn der aber schon wissen dass
der impfstoff in reichen sicher ist dann
bin ich auch noch mal nur das ist nicht
viel sinn macht vier wochen lang papiere
zu wälzen weil was anderes kann die
zulassungsstelle ja gar nicht tun die
macht ja keine eigene forschungsarbeit
um zu entscheiden ob man jetzt impfen
lässt ich persönlich habe mich ja schon
im august dafür entschieden das risiko
auf mich zu nehmen als proband da wusste
man noch nicht ob die verträglichkeit
gegeben ist sie ist gegeben bike
impfstoff genauso wie bei beyond eck und
moderner gwk den tübingern millionen
dosen auf vorrat produziert die können
nicht eingesetzt werden
und ich glaube dass man zumindest über
den weg der freiwilligkeit wenn jeder
unterschreibt ich nehme das risiko auf
mich so wie ich das gemacht habe als
probanden der studie beginnen könnte mit
dem empfinde ich sehe keinen großen sinn
mehr in der bürokratie die minister zu
lassen
getrieben wird also erstmal europa wälzt
papiere
stimmt das und die zweite frage sie
haben gesagt dass sie in wenigen tagen
damit rechnen allerdings sagt die
behörde die dafür zuständig ist dass es
erst eine sitzung ende dezember geht wie
passt das zusammen haben sie die neuen
informationen wir sind ja mitte dezember
jetzt glaube es ist heute der
vierzehnter dezember wenn ich richtig
informiert bin
und das bedeutet in wenigen tagen das
heißt wir reden nicht über monate oder
heute 113 für dezember und das soll am
27 29 sitzung geben ja und das kann dann
durchaus sein dass dann die entscheidung
getroffen wird
das muss schneller gehen außerdem also
ich bitte herzlich um herzlich um
verständnis dass ich diese diese
fachleute nicht unter druck setzen werde
weil ich nicht möchte dass am ende dann
behauptet wird wir hätten menschen in
gesundheitliche gefahren gebracht weil
wir zu sehr gedrängelt haben
das kann auch in großbritannien
passieren und es gab dort allergische
reaktionen im übrigen und dann hat man
sofort die impfungen verlangsamt und es
werden eben nicht millionen von menschen
im moment geimpft in großbritannien
sondern man hat vorsichtig angefangen um
zu schauen wie sind denn die ergebnisse
das ist bei einer solch frühen zulassung
gar nicht anders machbar und deshalb bin
ich überzeugt dass der unterschied zu
großbritannien am ende gar nicht so groß
sein wird und wer an ostern oder im
sommer des nächsten jahres wo mehr
menschen geimpft sind
in großbritannien oder in den usa oder
hier in europa das steht noch nicht fest
und da haben wir gute chancen
wir sehen haben sie sogar keinen
impfschutz auf diese länder also
zunächst einmal diese entscheidung der
zulassungsbehörde das ist ja einfach
entscheidung die kann ich durch politik
politiker ersetzt aber noch einmal wach
sind werden alle anderen asiatischen
ländern ich gehe es also sagen ja noch
als mitglied einer regierungsfraktion
einer der führenden gesundheitsexperten
in der in der in der spd sagt hier werde
die zulassung verschleppt denn das ist
dann schon eine politische aufgabe dafür
zu sorgen dass die entscheidung nicht
verschleppt wird
die entscheidung kann nicht der
politiker treffen aber dass das
verfahren nicht verschleppt wird dafür
müsste herr lauterbach eine erklärung
abgeben wir zu so einer erkenntnis kommt
ich möchte dass der impfstoff so schnell
wie möglich zugelassen wird aber wird
nach europäischen vorschriften zuge
würde mich überzeugt das nicht wenn
gesagt wird ja es gibt saudi arabien
schneller zu genannt ich möchte nicht
über saudi arabien sprechen das war ein
beispiel sie versuchen das jetzt in
irgendeine ecke zu biegen warum ich will
dass zum beispiel und ausländern ein
abstand eingehalten länder wie in
großbritannien
ja auch mal oder immer noch oder wie
auch immer mitglied der europäischen
union und sicherlich kein diktatorischer
start und sicherlich ist israel auch
eine demokratie und die usa auch so und
bleiben wir bei diesen beispielen bitte
warum können die das denn zu lassen und
warum sagen die experten nicht nur
lauterbach auch andere dass dieser
impfstoff dass das funktioniert warum
ist das bei uns anders dann brauchen wir
länger weil man muss ja ganz klar sagen
herr wissing es geht ja nicht nur darum
dass wir vielleicht ein bisschen ein
paar tage ein paar wochen ein bisschen
warten müssen nein es geht um
menschenleben jeden tag ja deswegen ist
es auch erklärungsbedürftig dass herr
lauterbach die these aufstellt geht
nicht um ende august wird um sie und es
geht um ein altmaier und umweltpark und
um die frage warum wir immer noch keinen
impfstoff haben wir wissen ja dass wir
die zulassung noch nicht haben und wenn
die zulassung die die über die kontrolle
der zulassungsbehörde ist nicht aufgabe
der opposition im deutschen bundestag
dann alles ist in uns auch völlig
wurscht denn überhaupt nicht überhaupt
nicht ich möchte nur nicht dass die
vorschriften nicht eingehalten werden
bei der zulassung weil ich davon
überzeugt bin dass die menschen
vertrauen diesen impfstoff haben müssen
ansonsten wird das nicht funktionieren
wenn wir ein paar leute impfen weil halt
einmal sagen ich bin bereit ein großes
risiko einzugehen
das werden nicht sehr viele seien in
deutschland die menschen vertrauen auf
unser gesundheitssystem und machen der
rauen die menschen vertrauen die
menschen auch werden macht aber die will
ich guten gewissens nie erschienen dann
muss ich das zu hauen zulassung nicht
verschleppt wird aber die menschen die
menschen vertrauen auf das
gesundheitssystem ich glaube worauf die
menschen nicht vertrauen er wird sich
unter altmaier ist das in brüssel oder
wo auch immer da so schnell gearbeitet
wird wie möglicherweise in anderen
ländern die bundeskanzlerin ist so oft
in brüssel
da muss sie erklären wenn ihr ein
mitglied ihrer ihrer koalition erklärt
da werde was verschleppt das kann ich
nicht darstellen ich bin nicht derjenige
der die brüsseler behörde zu überwachen
hat das ist schon aufgabe der
bundesregierung aber diese die sich zum
beispiel in den raum zu stellen halte
ich für sehr schwierig ich bin absolut
bei herrn altmaier wenn
wir können nicht durch politische
entscheidungen eine zulassungsbehörde
für einen impfstoff ersetzen das macht
keinen sinn
wir haben als politiker viele
erkenntnisse vielleicht viel erfahrung
in vielen bereichen aber ich muss ihnen
leider sagen ich kann so wie herr palmer
das offensichtlich kann die sicherheit
eines impfstoffs nicht beurteilen ich
bin ausgebildeter jurist und mache seit
über einem jahrzehnt berufspolitik aber
mit die zulassung von impfstoffen kenne
mich nun wirklich nicht aus und das hat
nicht bei der aufgabe wieder als
parlamentarier noch als minister einer
landesregierung
aber es ist wie gesagt aufgabe dafür zu
sorgen dass die behörden nicht
verschleppen schon gar nicht in einer
solchen pandemie phase deswegen müssen
diese thesen aufgeklärt werden so und
dann will ich ihnen noch mal sagen zum
schluss ich habe ja ein großes mitgefühl
für die situation in großbritannien wo
viel viel mehr menschen gestorben sind
als bei uns wo das gesundheitswesen
tatsächlich überlastet war
was bei uns gott sei dank noch nicht
erreicht es aber geschehen könnte wenn
wir nicht schnell genug reagieren und
ich habe viele freunde in großbritannien
die haben immer gesagt wir sind neidisch
auf euer gesundheitssystem in
deutschland und eure klinische und
medizinische versorgung und wenn das so
ist dass wir von all den menschen
bewundert werden um uns herum weil wir
es die letzten jahrzehnte gut gemacht
haben und auch in der pandemie gut
gemacht haben im vergleich zu anderen
dann meine ich sollten wir auch die
regeln dieses gesundheitssystems
befolgen die griechen beim ersten besten
mal über den haufen wirft sie sprechen
über die medizinische versorgung in
deutschland noch einmal genau das ist
das worüber ich jetzt sprechen möchte
mit ihnen drein denn heute hat markus
söder in der pressekonferenz einen satz
gesagt der doch für diskussionen gesorgt
hat er sprach nämlich über die tisch in
deutschland
die kliniken echt sind die echtzeit
derzeit unter der belastung teilweise
gibt es schon triage in deutschland
nämlich dass man entscheidet wer
behandelt wird oder wer woanders sind
verlegt werden muss herr palmer wenn sie
diesen satz hören teilweise gibt es
schon trias in deutschland was geht
ihnen da durch den kopf
der ist falsch wenn jemand nur in der
andere klinik verlegt wird heißt es
nicht dass entschieden wird jemand nicht
zu behandeln
und warum glauben sie hat markus söder
diesen
satz benutzt geht es darum eine
zunehmende stimmung die man erzeugen
müsste um mehr panik um angst bei den
menschen wie sehen sie das
das steht mir wirklich nicht so ich bin
ich hellseher und ich kenne auch die
motive von markus söder nicht dann
müssen sie andere exegeten fragen
ich würde er noch mal denn sie erlauben
einsatz zur impfstoff zulassung sagen
die frage ist doch ob das verfahren der
impfstoff zulassung auf diese christ
zugeschnitten ist ich glaube nicht da
müssen zwei berichterstatter länder
gefunden wird nichts aus schweden und
frankreich sind dann müssen die in
diesem ganzen eu prozedere sich darauf
verständigen die übersetzung braucht da
geht es hin und her und es kostet sehr
sehr viel zeit und ich glaube dass
dieses verfahren auf seine notlage nicht
zugestellt ist wenn herr söder recht
hatten wir vor trotzdem können wir uns
standard prozeduren bei impfstoff
zulassungen nicht leisten in die phase 2
studien sind abgeschlossen und das ist
die verträglichkeit frage das heißt
sicher sinn diese impfstoffe
also herr palmer betont nochmal aus
seiner sicht sind die impfstoffe sicher
aber ich möchte von ihnen beiden gerne
auch wissen was sie über die triage
aussage von herrn söder in der
pressekonferenz wie sie das bewerten
herr wissen also die erklärung der
gegeben hat die ist offensichtlich
falsch denn wenn die patienten in eine
andere klinik verlegt werden dann hat
das mit triage nichts zu tun dass es was
ganz normales es kommt immer wieder vor
es gibt es gibt es auch bei unfällen das
eben in der eine klinik ein chirurg im
team gerade nicht zur verfügung steht
man in eine andere klinik gebracht wird
und dort operiert wird das ist keine
triage sondern das ist medizinische
versorgung also das gegenteil von trier
das herzland muss er selbst erklären ich
kann nachvollziehen aber ist das sind ja
auch so macht keinen sinn jetzt den
leuten angst zu machen die dinge zu
traumatisieren die lage ist ernst man
muss jetzt verantwortungsvoll handeln
aber wir müssen jetzt nicht übertreiben
herr altmaier weiter angst geschürt wenn
man von trial springt nein ich glaube
das hat er überhaupt gar nicht vorgehabt
branche kommt ja aus dem französischen
prix ag und das heißt eine entscheidung
treffen zwischen zwei alternativen
das heißt sie haben
im konfliktfall ein bett und ein
beatmungsgerät problem sind ja nicht die
betten das problem ist das personal das
problem sind in einigen ländern die
beatmungsgeräte und dann müssen sie
entscheiden wer bekommt das vor der
situation stehen wir nicht aber es ist
so und da hatte markus söder recht dass
wir zum ersten mal die situation haben
dass wir nicht alle patienten irgendwo
zu einem krankenhaus kommen dort auch
behandeln können das ist bei einer
normalen erkältung nicht das problem
hier wo es um eine gewisse dringlichkeit
geht kann es zum problem werden
wir haben in deutschland insgesamt noch
einige tausend freie intensivbetten wie
zur verfügung stehen für behandlung und
wenn das exponentielle wachstum nicht
gestoppt wird dann werden die sehr
schnell voll laufen und deshalb
entscheidet sich in den tagen zwischen
weihnachten und dem zehnten januar ob es
uns gelingt die handlungsfähigkeit des
gesundheitssystems aufrecht zu erhalten
das kann dann immer noch bedeuten dass
in einem hotspot die krankenhäuser
belegt sind und dass man in den
benachbarten landkreis oder vielleicht
noch weiter fahren muss aber das heißt
wir können den menschen auch helfen wenn
wir das nicht rechtzeitig machen dann
werden uns auch die impfungen davor
nicht bewahren
aber herr söder hat ja auch noch ein
zweiter satz gesagt er hat deutschland
in die nähe von bergamo gerückt wo er
die triage aussage nochmal eine ganz
andere bedeutung bekommt wo man doch
sagen muss er altmaier
wenn man über bergamo spricht gehört
dann zur wahrheit nicht auch das in ganz
italien ist soviel intensivbetten gibt
wie in nrw also hantieren wir da gerade
auch mit den falschen zahlen wenn wir
den deutschen so muss man es ja sagen
und dem material spricht die es dann am
ende nicht gibt so eine angst macht noch
einmal wir haben viel mehr
intensivbetten als in italien
wir haben allerdings in den letzten
wochen erlebt dass sie zunehmend belegt
sind und das zunehmend weniger freie zur
verfügung stehen
das ist im augenblick noch lösbar und
handelbar
aber auch nur dann wenn wir die zahl der
infektionen im griff erhalten wir hatten
im frühjahr auf dem höhepunkt der
pandemie 5700 bestätigte fälle pro tag
wir haben jetzt über 20.000 fälle
bestätigt pro tag das zeigt dass es mit
einer anderen geschwindigkeit und
dynamik einhergeht und deshalb müssen
wir handeln ich glaube den
handlungsdruck wollte markus söder noch
einmal deutlich machen und das ist die
verantwortung der politik aber ist zu
sagen zu sagen wir müssen jetzt handeln
um schwere gefahren in einigen wochen zu
vermeiden aber ist dass am ende
tatsächlich soweit kommen wir wieder
auch die frage ob das was er palma
nämlich in tübingen gemacht hat wenn wir
uns die zahlen anschauen
herr palmer was die alten in unserem
land angeht da gab es auch eine
statistik an diesem wochenende wo man
eben ganz klar sieht das der incidents
wert insbesondere bei über 90 jährigen
bei über 400 500 eben liegt was ja ein
ganz klarer hinweis darauf ist dass wir
uns eben nicht genügend um die älteren
kümmern um diejenigen in pflege und
altenheimen deswegen meine frage wenn
man sich besser um die kümmern könnte
wenn man die besser schützen würde
bräuchten wir dann am ende so ein
lockdown nicht das würde lager nicht
ausreichend dafür sind die zahlen
insgesamt zu hoch aber es wäre ein
wichtiger baustein
jetzt halt die belastung der
intensivstationen deutlich drückt wenn
man sich besonders um die kümmert den
hohes risiko haben schwer zu erkranken
das nennt sich protection strategie
steht in jedem pandemie plan wurde aber
leider in deutschland auch nicht
umgesetzt oder nur sehr verhalten weil
wir eine verwechslung der begriffe
diskriminierung und differenzierung
haben wann immer man gesagt hat wir
müssen jetzt die alten anders behandeln
würde man sofort mit dem vorwurf der
diskriminierung konfrontiert dabei ist
verstärkt das schutz ja das gegenteil
von diskriminierungen nämlich gezieltes
differenziertes handeln und ich hoffe
dass wir die weihnachtszeit nutzen um
auch diese vermischung von begriffen in
ordnung zu bringen
wir müssen uns ganz besonders um die
kümmern die das höchste risiko tragen
weil wir sehen was ist da ihre analyse
und vor allem was kann man jetzt konkret
in ganz deutschland tun um endlich die
alten zu schützen man muss ja sagen wir
reden seit neun monaten einig über
dieses thema und passiert ist eigentlich
nichts wenn meine partei fordere seit
vielen monaten warum wollte niemand ob
sie ja das ist muss bundesregierung sich
fragen das
wegen haben wir diese dinge ja kritisch
begleitet in den letzten monaten aber es
hilft ja nichts zurück zu blicken jetzt
kann man die dinge besser machen jetzt
fängt man ja an mit fb zwei masken
verstärkten tests die variablen gruppen
zu schützen ich halte das für die
richtige strategie ich halte das für
dringend notwendig in absoluter man dass
das keine diskriminierung ist sondern
dass das schutz ist halte diese idee
schon dass man sagt alte menschen zu
schützen mit nämlich vielen tests mit
effet zwei masken würde sie ausgrenzen
nein es schützt sie vor der infektion
und darum muss es doch gehen
und dieses in der breite agieren wie
gesagt wellenbrecher lockdown ist kein
erfolg gewesen das muss man leider so
feststellen und es war ein von anfang an
ein experiment und offensichtlich ich
vermute dass auch rechenfehler weil er
bei der statistik gemacht worden sind
das war so wenig passiert ist an anderen
er ist zunächst schon mal was passiert
war nämlich das exponentielle wachstum
aufgehört hat die zahlen gingen auch an
einigen tagen zurück aber leider hat
auch das aufgehört und warum weil das
ursprüngliche paket was wir ja was hier
vorgeschlagen worden war dann nur
teilweise beschlossen worden ist nämlich
der wellenbrecher lockdown es gab ja
noch andere maßnahmen die dann das sage
ich gar nicht als kritik aber die dann
am ende es nicht geschafft haben in die
praktische anwendung und aus diesen aber
wenn sie jetzt so weit zurückschauen und
lernen muss man lernen und das tun wir
auch und deshalb habe ich vorhin auch
noch einmal ganz deutlich gesagt dass
wir als boris palmer mit zahlen
unterlegt ist ja ein doch sehr
beachtlicher erfolg und deshalb wünsche
ich mir dass man überall in deutschland
sich auch damit beschäftigt und überlegt
was man davon übernehmen das heißt wo es
jetzt nur für die erste leyen im
kabinett sondern auch in den schutz der
alten ja er hat ja selbst gesagt es gibt
keinen absoluten schutz er hat jetzt
auch infektionen in diesem bereich aber
eben weniger als viele andere
und dann dieses kapital gebunden also
ich bin nicht aber bestimmt gab der die
kabinetts einladungen ausspricht ist
immer noch die bundeskanzlerin und ich
glaube es geht auch gar nicht im
kabinett sitzen sondern es geht darum
dass man vor ort das was halt partner
macht kann hoch interessant sein für
oberberg
meister in anderen vergleichbaren
städten muss vor ort entschieden und
gelöst werden die bundesregierung ist
bereit zu helfen und deshalb
unterstützen wir bei den f e p2 masken
deshalb haben wir auch in der
vergangenheit gelder zur verfügung
gestellt
ich persönlich halte testen für eine
ganz wichtige sache und ich glaube dass
vieles von dem was in tübingen probiert
worden ist tatsächlich in die richtige
richtung zeigt jan meyer herr wissing
zum abschluss möchte ich noch ein thema
ansprechen was auch vielen eltern viele
schüler betrifft und möchte da
professorin susanne lin kissling mit in
die runde bringen
sie ist uns bereits zugeschaltet genau
vom philologenverband und sich die
fragen ist das was jetzt heute passiert
ist das richtige für die schulen oder
hat man da ein versprechen gebrochen
dass die schulen eben nicht geschlossen
werden
sein name ist susanne link klitzing ich
werde es nur den seinerzeit gesagt
entschuldigen sie das ist der späte
stunde geschuldet gehirn sendungen die
wir heute gemacht haben ich glaube es
ihnen alles gut was haben wir mit dem
jetzigen beschluss eine uneinigkeit
wir haben bestimmte länder in denen die
schulen geschlossen werden und wir haben
in den präsenz aus zur iss bedeutet dass
lehrkräfte vor der aufgabe stehen nicht
sie als ich in der woche sächlichen
immer klappt weg viel geld und ein
gemeinsam eine sprechende division gut
hin so altmaier herr wissing vielleicht
ganz schnell aus ihrer sicht was muss in
den schulen passieren damit das ganze
besser wird und dass vielleicht beim
übernächsten lockt da und wir hoffen
alle nicht dass er kommt aber wenn das
ganze noch länger geht dass die schule
neben wieder offen sein können und dass
die schüler lernen das ist etwas was
mich total ärgert wir sind in meinem
thema digitalisierung der schulen seit
jahren nicht dort wo wir eigentlich sein
müssten
das ist nicht nur eine frage
in krisenzeiten und pandemien ich war in
serbien im letzten jahr dort ist
digitaler unterricht seit einiger zeit
bereits eingeführt mit großem erfolg und
ich habe überhaupt gar kein verständnis
wenn es nicht möglich ist schnell dafür
zu sorgen dass die notwendigen
technischen die notwendigen software
aber haben sich mal wieder als
bundesregierung haben dafür geld zur
verfügung gestellt dieses geld muss
abfließen es muss umgesetzt werden und
wenn es irgendwo schwierigkeiten gibt
muss man darüber reden
ich war warum du hast dich habe ich
festgestellt habe ja nur verkehrt
klar wir haben allerdings wir haben
allerdings als bund auch nur die
möglichkeit finanzielle mittel zur
verfügung zu stellen umgesetzt werden
muss es anderswo
ich mache überhaupt keine
schuldzuweisungen aber tatsache ist dass
digitaler unterricht flächendeckend in
deutschland noch nicht möglich ist so
wissen sie sind in rheinland-pfalz also
sie sind da im kabinett passiert nichts
ändern das hatte ich so dass nichts
passiert also wir haben sehr viele
mittel abgerufen wir haben die
digitalisierung vorangetrieben den
letzten monaten natürlich müssen die
schülerinnen und schüler in ein gerät
haben um digitalen unterhaltung
doch das problem ist aber dass es sehr
unterschiedlich ist weil die die das
bildungssystem nicht ausreichend auf
digitale unterrichtsform ausgelegt ist
und vorbereitet ist wir haben
lehrerinnen und lehrer die das sehr viel
freude daran haben die das sehr gerne
machen es gibt klassen gehen das sehr
gut funktioniert es gibt andere klassen
in das weniger gut funktioniert das ist
ein prozess der in deutschland wie in
vielen bereichen der digitalisierung zu
spät angestoßen wurde
da müssen wir jetzt schneller werden und
müssen gas geben im übrigen ist es auch
so dass nicht überall flächendeckend wie
eine ausreichende versorgung mit
glasfaser oder breitband haben auch das
ist ein thema
da haben wir ja in den letzten jahren
viel vorangebracht gemeinsam mit dem
bund aber auch das ist spät aufgesetzt
worden in deutschland
man hat viel zu lange das treiben lassen
und in der schule die nicht ans
breitband angeschlossen ist kann auch
keinen digitalen unterricht von
professoren den klitzing abschluss frage
an sie
was ist ihre analyse woran liegt das
dass es nicht wirklich voran geht und
vor allem droht uns jetzt durch den
erneuten lockdown eine richtige
bildungskrise in deutschland das sind
zwei fragen zur ersten frage wir haben
uns dem grundsätzlichen problem der
bildungsfinanzierung jetzt nicht
gestellt und das liegt darin begründet
dass die einzelne schule durch die
jeweilige kommune finanziert wird die
kommunen haben ganz unterschiedlich viel
geld und setzen auch unterschiedliche
schwerpunkte
wir haben ganz zuschüsse sowohl durch
die länder als auch durch den bund und
diese prinzipiell sei normal rangelei
bildungsfinanzierung die ist ein teil
der ursache für den zustand an den
schulen und da müssten wir einmal ran
zur zweiten frage wir müssen schauen
dass wir die emotionalen und die lern
verluste für schülerinnen und schüler
gering halten möglichst geringen die
emotionalen verluste haben etwas mit
zuverlässigkeit zu tun die der
schülerinnen und schülern bieten dafür
müssten räume besser ausgestattet sein
heizung funktionieren lüftungsgeräte die
hoffentlich funktionieren fenster
unterstützen einerseits und andererseits
brauchen wir die konkrete einstellung
von lehrkräften um schülerinnen und
schüler fachspezifisch zu fördern ein
problem in vielen bundesländern neu
ausgebildete lehrkräfte werden vor den
sommerferien entlassen und nach den
sommerferien eingestellt diese
lehrkräfte gibt es die könnten
fachspezifische individuelle förderung
in diesen ferien leisten wir leisten uns
sie nicht einzustellen
herzlichen dank für ihre analyse und ich
wünsche ihnen vor allem viel erfolg dass
das in den nächsten wochen nicht noch
dramatischer wird und vor allem den
schülern im gesamten land ja meine
abschlussfrage in der runde für heute
eine spannende emotionale diskussion
über impfstoff über triage über das was
wir in deutschland tun sollten
herr palmer an sie wenn sie jetzt auf
weihnachten schauen was wünschen sie
sich von der bundesregierung zu
weihnachten habe ich keine wünsche wäre
alle entscheidungen sind getroffen
ich wünsche mir nur dass wir die zeit
zur vorbereitung nutzen der mit der
doktor ich sehr viel länger als bis zum
zehnten januar andauern muss die beiden
punkte habe ich genannt effiziente
kontakt verfolgung und besser geschützte
risikogruppen da müssen wir bis 10
januar fortschritte erzielen
herr wissing haben sie einen speziellen
wunsch an die kanzlerin zu weihnachten
also ich wünsche mir dass wir in den
nächsten wochen jetzt nicht ständig neue
diskussionen bekommen welcher
konstellation mit 54 36 oder sonstigen
leuten man sich treffen soll oder nicht
treffen soll sondern dass wir eine
stringente strategie jetzt entwickeln
wie wir in den nächsten monaten und
corona wird uns über den 10 januar
hinaus beschäftigen und begleiten wie
wir eine stringente strategie habe
dieser pandemie umgehen
wir bieten als freidemokraten unsere
unterstützung an
ich würde mir auch wünschen dass man den
deutschen bundestag als parlament
stärker einbindet es werden uns gut
getan wenn man den letzten monaten
expertenanhörungen durchgeführt hätten
auch transmit transparenz mit
öffentlichkeitsbeteiligung das hätte uns
gut getan und das ist nicht zu spät so
etwas nachzuholen
es ist nicht der weisheit letzter
schluss dass alle paar wochen in dieser
runde der ministerpräsidenten und
ministerpräsidenten mit der kanzlerin zu
besprechen die menschen wollen
transparenz sie wollen debatte und das
kann man jetzt in den nächsten monaten
hin kriegen wir haben alle die hand
dafür gereicht ich glaube das muss man
am großen schulterschluss in deutschland
das sind viele wünsche ich weiß nicht ob
die alle unseren baum passen aber halt
mal für sie eine ganz spezielle
abschlussfrage denn viele kinder viele
jugendliche viele eltern fragen sich ja
auch so ein bisschen kommt denn dieses
jahr überhaupt der weihnachtsmann und
kommt also bei mir zu hause in
ostfriesland ist das christkind
haben sie das gefühl dass auch das
ausfallen könnte oder können sie da als
wirtschaftsminister zumindest eine
kleine versicherung geben dass der
weihnachtsmann doch noch kommen denn wir
wollen ja das war nachdem stattfindet
ich weiß nicht ob alle es geschafft
haben die geschenke rechtzeitig zu
kaufen
ich habe vorhin gesagt wer lieber ein
bisschen mehr einschränken dieses jahr
und dann gutschein unterm weihnachtsbaum
legen und dann kommt der christ der
weihnachtsmann bringt den gutschein und
der wird dann eingelöst wenn es wieder
möglich ist ich wünsche mir dass dies
auf einige jahre hin das letzte
weihnachtsfest war dass wir unter so
traurigen bedingungen verbringen müssen
ich wünsche mir dass die familien
zusammenkommen können dort wo es
vertretbar ist dass niemand infiziert
wird und dass wir alle zusammen die
solidarität und die gemeinsamkeit
parteiübergreifend die heute sichtbar
geworden ist auch in den nächsten wochen
und monaten zustande bringen ich habe
mir nämlich die frage gestellt weil es
da ein besonders emotionale rede ich
glaube im irischen parlament war es wo
zumindest den kindern versprochen wurde
also der weihnachtsmann jetzt ganz
generell gesprochen da ist von corona
nicht betroffen schön wäre es soweit
herzlichen dank in die runde
herzlichen dank boris palmer nach
tübingen viel erfolg bei ihrem konzept
was die altenheimer angeht herzlichen
dank bundeswirtschaftsminister peter
altmaier der sehr viel zu tun hat
sicherlich jetzt was die hilfen angeht
und herzlichen dank fdp-generalsekretär
und wirtschaftsminister in rheinland
pfalz volker wissing das war's mit die
richtigen fragen nach einem marathon tag
muss man sagen wir halten fest der
knaller lockdown ist da bild bleibt auch
da natürlich morgen und wir berichten
weiter live über das was kommt und da
kommt noch einiges
[Musik]